over the past few years we've seen I
think a very clear separation between
work and life right you you it used to
be you work nine to five everything
before nine and after five was
considered personal time
and over the past few years we've been
talking about this concept of work life
integration do you think that's a good
thing or a bad thing so step back
am I getting to go what I want out of
life is this the path am I prioritizing
am I organizing it so I don't want to
say
it's intrinsically wrong to blur them
together or it's intrinsically right
if it's bringing you the things that you
want
than do that but do reflect on it and
then you know so much of reflecting this
whole idea of reflecting and doing the
things that is best from you for you
overlooks the fact
that it's habit and your subliminal is
going to drive you so it's not easy to
just say I'm going to make this decision
and now I'm going to do this thing I'm
going to stop eating the potato chips
I'm going to start doing that you have
to set out
how you're going to build that habit
to do the things you want to do I think